hello everyone I was gonna show you this
game yesterday right after it was played
but my toothache got so severe I had to
go to the ER and I did get a very nice
painkiller there but it really did
nothing to help me so you know I really
didn't know what to do and I had to go
all the way to Zagreb to find a dentist
who was willing to open up his workshop
and to fix me up so by the time I was
done with it it was like 2:00 a.m. when
I got back home to my city needless to
say was a very eventful day but now it's
it's it's better you know manageable my
right side is a bit swollen up but that
is not a reason not to show a nice room
for the game between sergey kurginyan
maxime beaugeois holograph from around 4
of the 2018 norway championship now as i
mentioned in my previous video Dingley
rain broke his hip well I don't know it
was if it did if it's like a broken hip
or it was just a mini fracture he did
have an operation and he is a game
against Fabiana called wanna was
postponed so only four games were played
in round four but they were four very
eventful games so before we check out
this very nice game between kurakin and
la Grove we do have some photos first
some photos from the cooking contest as
during the rest day the players did have
a cooking contest so here we have it's
not of the highest quality but you can
see Aragon there slicing up that garlic
magnus carlsen on the Left is
approaching him you remember last year
the players were milking cows and
driving tractors here a very nice photo
of eleven our onion and Maxine washi ala
Grove they were there were teammates
during this cooking contest all the
players worked in teams here we have
Bingley Ren and Vishwanathan Anand ding
and Anand the word the winners of the
cooking contest and it's very
interesting
ding broke his hip but he didn't really
know it was broken so he went to the
cooking contest after his accident and
only then after the cooking contest he
went to see a doctor and then they told
him dude you have to like go go get an
operation so everything is well now and
his game against Khurana
was only postponed here also a very nice
a very nice photo of Levon Aronian and
Maxine where Sheila Grubb preparing
vegetables and here enough food cooking
photos a a photo from this game so that
there's a car key and Maxime on the
right so let's let's check it out
Maxime has the black pieces and kurakin
opens with d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight
to c3 and the d5 as we already mentioned
it's the groom fell defense C captures
Knight captures and E for so the
exchange variation the most standard of
lines Knight captures be captures and
Bishop to g7 Bishop to c4 and now the
immediate c5 some maybe if there are
some real beginners watching this video
this may not seem like a natural move
but it really is notice that a capturing
or pushing d5 is impossible because this
bishop is eyeing the c3 pawn then you
would get this very nice fork so you
know just just putting it out there so
nice to e2 also adding more protection
to the d4 pawn and guarding the the c3
pawn Knight to c6
we have Bishop to e3 castles castles and
b6 now and here Kirk in place D captures
on c5 seems like a pawn sacrifice but
Queen to c7 and now you could capture
another point here would see characters
on b6 and after a capture some b6 you
would be up upon temporarily but you're
it's very hard to imagine that Kerrigan
would would be prepared for a line like
this and going into it you would only go
into maxime preparation so after Queen
to see seven Knights to d4 a nice active
move Knight to e5 attacking the bishop
we have Bishop nice to b5 attacking the
Queen and c7 Queen moves and Bishop the
back to e 2 preparing f4 to kick away
the knife from a nice central square
that is e 5b captures on c5 grabbing
back the pawn rope to be won and now a
six there are no good discoveries to be
made with the night so nice to a3 the
queen is now attacked Quint back to see
seven and now f4 instead of moving
tonight immediately Maxime makes an
in-between rook to e8 look to the eight
first attacking the Queen Queen to c2
and now Knight to g4 captures Bishop
captures and f5 now Cara Kane is ready
to bust open Maxim's King side G
captures an f5 we have a ninth the c-4
first and in between move and now of
course grabbing a pawn isn't possible
because if you capture then Queen
captures then your Bishop is attacked
and also rook to b7 would be extremely
would be an extremely active move for
white going for e7 so that this would be
allowing too much activity for white for
the price of one pawn
so after Knight c4 e6 now we have h3 now
Bishop age five and now capturing an f5
in captures an f5 and Bishop to g5 now
attacking maxims rook and here maxime
ignores this threat he plays f4
preparing a very wild move that is upon
2 F 3 and now kurakin doesn't capture
grab the exchange if this brush up on g5
is a very nice piece the rope can a 8 is
completely out of the game at the moment
is doing nothing so while you could grab
the exchange immediately and this is in
fact the best move recommended by the
engine kurakin decides not to do this as
it would just activate black's other
rook
so first Queen to f2 now with ideas of
capturing the f4 pawn and after the
bishop moves there will be there will be
some nice threats against the f7 pawn so
here it comes
instead of playing something like rook
to e8 now getting the rook out of the
way that could be followed with the
Bishop captures and I for Queen c6 and
Knight to d6 this is so much activity
for white rookie to attack in the Queen
Queen to g3 now there are so many
threats White has and the white position
is simply simply very nice rook to b7
also an idea black also has some threats
you know towards the GTO pawn but white
is holding this very nicely so instead
of moving the rook Maxime proceeds with
his plan he plays pawn to
three so what do you do here here
kurakin decided to grab the rock on d8
so rook capture a bishop capture sandy
eight rook after sandy eight and now
instead of capturing on f3 if you
captured G captures on f3 again you're
giving black too much activity after
Queen to f4 rook to d1 attacking the
rook rook captures rook captures and now
Bishop captures on c3 black would be
black would be completely fine here even
better
of course you can never capture the
denied and c4 if you capture it then
rook to d8 will win the game immediately
after Bishop blocks only move Queen to
g3 check now if you move the King broke
a press f8 will be checkmate so after
you block this then Queen to these sex
comes and there is no defense against
Queen captures on f8 so after this rook
captures and e8 we have Queen to h4 now
attacking the bishop on h5 first F
capture Sanji to attacking Carrigan's
rook on f1 we have rook F 2 e1 and now
comes Bishop to f3
Bishop to f3 is a very important move
not just because it protects the G to
pawn but to really see how strong this
move is first you have to realize why is
Bishop to g6 a losing move for black so
this is a very nice position for you to
analyze feel free to pause the video
here and find the winning move for
Kerrigan in this position I will give it
a couple of seconds as usual so you know
feel free you know go wild for those of
you who found it congratulations you are
an excellent rook lifter and for those
of you who just won't enjoy show the
move you have to make here is this very
nice rook lift rook to b7 and once you
see it it becomes it really becomes
apparent of course you're forcing black
to capture the rook and then Queen will
capture on the a and if you do this
obvious threat Queen captures Queen
captures then likes only move is Bishop
terrific and now not roki eight which
you know everyone would immediately play
because then black will have some
counter play after Queen to be won but
instead Knight to be six and now the
threat of course is nice to d7
or the idea is the same Queen will
capture on f8 and the black can do very
little about this if black stops this
with Bishop to a5 for example
then comes rocky 8 but then night is
blocking the Queen from coming to be one
so here a nice idea
so if black tries to unpin then comes 97
and still the thready screen captures if
you move the bishop you can there's
really no good square for the bishop we
Nevada check King moves black loses a
piece and ended the game now white is a
whole rook up and on the other hand
after rugby 7 even if you don't capture
the rook if you even if you go
Quincy 8 for example simply guarding the
rook that's even worse because now
Knight b6 you are forcing Queen to
capture the rook and when Queen captures
you already have a knight here
so simply Queen captures Bishop to f8
and now 97 and the King is now ng 8
instead of on g7 so there is no defense
Queen captures on my faith wins the game
so a very nice idea
Bishop to f3 not only guards this but
also prevents rook to b7 very nice idea
by Maxie we have rook to e3 attacking
the bishop and now push up the c6 again
Maxine has to keep an eye on that b7
square we have rugby t1 doubling up rook
to e7 was a was a nice idea but that
that can always be played better yet now
Kirk in first doubles up on the e-file
rook to f8 and now Knight to e5 either
forcing Maxime to give up that strong
dark square bishop for the night or you
know it's a very nice square for the
knight Bishop d5 doesn't allow the
knight to be captured and now rook to g3
now attacking the bishop we have f6
attacking the knight from 9th to d3 and
now Bishop captures an a2 and this is a
the you know the the point of no return
for Maxime the the best move here would
be king - h8 simply moving out of the
pin and now black will black will have
some chances although not a lot of
chances but after this Bishop captures
on a 2 here Cara King shows the
Frenchman that you know this definitely
was not a free pawn here kurakin plays
c4 and for the price of one pawn this
Bishop is now out of the game
c4 blocks this Bishop out of the game
the Queen is protecting c4 we have
Quinta
six maxime tries to get the Queen into
the game via some Queen 2d for ideas
maybe exchange in Queens but now comes
Knight to f4
not a carton doesn't allow to exchange
Queens because he's his on the attack
and he wants all of the pieces on the
board here capturing with the bishop
doesn't doesn't give you anything
because Knight h5 simply this this this
threat isn't you know unstoppable if you
tried rook f7 to prevent it then rocky 8
is coming and after rook to f8 and now
comes to Knight captures on f6 Bishop
cannot capture because it spins rook
cannot capture because it's been from
this rook so if you capture with the
Queen then Queen captures wins the Queen
if you go king - h8 then Queen captures
on h7 is checkmate
but even after king f7 you're still
getting checkmated Queen h5 King
captures rook rook checkers on f3 and
the King has nowhere to go Queen has the
block and the rook captures on f4 will
be checkmate
so after Knight to f4 Queen to d4 check
was played King moves and now Bishop
captures on c4 here Kirk in plate Queen
to h6
with the threat of Queen captures and g7
we have f5 now the Queen is also
protecting the bishop on g7 but Knight
to h5 and unmoved 38 even before the
time control was reached
Maxine via holograph resigns the game
why did he resign well there's really
nothing to do here the bishop on g7 is
attacked three times there's really no
good way to defend it any tricks with
pawn to g1 Queen don't work and if you
try rock f7 then again the same idea
applies to rook e8 check rook has the
block you can't move any other pieces
and then simply comes rook after some g7
King moves and Queen captures on h7 will
be checkmate so after Knight to h5
Maxima sherrilyn Grove and a very nice
victory for servi-car keen who after 3
draws wins his first game in the Norway
Chess Championship I will show one more
game from round 4 and then we're gonna
check out the standings after after
round 4 it's not the real standings
because I think we're in still has to
play his game against Khurana but you
know
just to get a general idea so now I
would like to thank Danny McCullough and
Alvaro Fernandez de la Rosa for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon from whit another game from
round 4 of the 2018 Norway Championship
thank you all and I'll see you soon